I consider myself to be a very rational
and scientifically-minded human being,
and as a result, I find myself
believing in some scientific theories
that when I say them out loud
kind of make me sound like I'm insane.
Oh this is gonna...
Alright, I'm going to try to convince you
that in our own universe,
there is a person identical to you
watching a YouTube video
identical to this one on a planet
and in a solar system that is exactly
the same as the one that we are in
and that there is not only one
of these carbon copies,
but there are an infinite number
of them throughout our universe.
Do I have your attention?
Okay, let's do this.
Firstly, an example.
Imagine a man who has a hundred
different shirts, 250 different ties,
and just two pairs of trousers,
leaving him with a possible 50,000
different unique outfit combinations.
Most people don't have
that many clothes.
He is unique.
He's exceptional.
He is our example.
He's Example Man.
He wears all the clothes.
However, if we were to imagine
that Example Man were immortal
and that he never bought any other
clothes in his life, we can accept, I think,
that eventually he would have to start
repeating his outfit combinations.
Bearing that example in mind, here is where
things start to go completely bonkers.
Me and you and everything in
our entire universe is made up
of a combination of different
types of particles,
and the particular combinations of
all of these different particles
can make up anything from
the simplest hydrogen gases
floating around the universe to the incredibly
complicated neurological systems
that make up our brains and our memories
and, in turn, us as individuals.
That is what
science tells us.
The sheer number of possible combinations
that these particles can make
is so big that I am not going to bother
trying to figure out what that number is.
However, because there are only a certain
number of different types of particles,
that means that the number
of different combinations
those particles can
make is finite,
meaning that, just
like Example Man,
if you give the universe enough space,
it will have to start repeating itself.
And it just so happens that the prevailing
scientific theory at the moment
is that the universe
is infinitely big.
So, if that's true, then that means that
the universe has to have repeated itself,
which means that there has to be an
infinite number of different copies
of me and of you and of our planets
scattered throughout the cosmos.
Please believe me when I say I know
how absurd this idea sounds,
but I also know that it comes
from a place of observing
our universe and making a
logical conclusion about it.
It is not fanciful thinking.
It is rational thinking.
It just doesn't feel like
it should be true.
Now, obviously when
it come to science,
how we feel about an idea has absolutely
zero impact on how true it is or isn't,
but, for me personally, I kind of
like the idea of infinite Charlies,
and I will explain why.
What the theory dictates is that
not only are there an infinite number
of identical versions of us
scattered around the universe,
but also that there are an infinite number
of ever so slightly different versions
of us scattered
throughout the universe.
And so, for me personally, when I'm
going about my day to day life
and I make a decision that I regret or
I find myself missing an opportunity,
I fail to tell a girl that I like
her or something,
then what I like to think about is that
somewhere out there in the universe,
there is a Charlie who did tell
that girl that he liked her,
and not only is there one of them
but there are an infinite number
of Charlies that made the decision
that I was hoping make
and, for some reason,
that just makes me feel better.
So, there you go.
That's how my brain works.
Hopefully, you found that as
interesting as I think it is
and that you don't
think I'm too crazy.
Quick update: my second
short film is now in the can,
and I'm hoping to have a version
of it or at least a scene of it
or something to show
at VidCon this year,
so if you're going to VidCon,
look out for that.
Annnnd yeah.
Goodbye.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.